let's set the stage with our Hannity
watch on these very wall negotiations
that have been ongoing now for days
Democrats they just been up to their old
tricks once again playing politics
trying to torpedo border security talks
with what is an outrageous demand
actually aim think about this at
curtailing the effectiveness of ice we
know they want to abolish it in the end
but over the weekend we learned
Democratic negotiators look at this they
were pushing for an arbitrary cap on the
number of illegal immigrants that ice
would be allowed to detain at one time
and the Democrats they wanted to set the
cap at only sixteen thousand five
hundred individuals in other words if
capacity exceeds that number for any
reason unvetted unverified undocumented
illegal immigrants would essentially
pour free into the United States and
border enforcement would be powerless to
stop them even criminals those with
violent track records gang ties cartel
ties would all be free to enter the
country illegally and not face any kind
of immigration detention now keep in
mind look at the last two years alone
two hundred and sixty six thousand
arrests of criminal aliens have been
carried out including a hundred thousand
assault charges thirty thousand sex
crimes charges four thousand murder
homicide charges and as we speak nearly
180,000 illegal immigrants live right
here in the US including some of those
violent felons they are already facing
removal orders but Democrats they want
to cap ice detention at 16,500 well
that's insane because let's say sixteen
thousand five hundred one what if it
turned out to be a murderer a rapist
part of a drug cartel as President Trump
he's been calling for more funding more
resources more security to tackle the
scourge of drugs gang violence human
trafficking sex trafficking of young
girls and more Democrats seem content
with trying to make border security
what more difficult now look the
president's fighting this
it is a life-and-death issue this is
about your family's safety and security
first Democrats once again playing just
pure politics it's pretty outrageous
they seem to hate Donald Trump that that
is more important to them based on their
actions than your security your family
security more important than daca
dreamers even furloughed employees that
they claim to care so much about you
know these are the things they say they
wanted just a few short years ago when
Obama's second term
they were advocating the same policies
Donald Trump is now pushing hard for as
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
put it in the Democratic Party the
radicals as I've been saying the radical
extremist new socialist Democratic Party
they're running the show take a look
this is a poison pill that no
administration not this one not the
previous one would or should ever accept
imagine the absurdity of this House
Democrats want to set a limit on how
many criminal aliens our government can
detain this is where some Democrats are
I get out of jail free card for
criminals because the radical left
doesn't like us immigrations and Customs
Enforcement now for months we told you
the radical extreme left has consumed
the Democratic Party now we're watching
what open borders that agenda play out
in real time they want to eliminate ice
but Americans now are waking up and
waking up very very quickly and seeing
how extreme this new democratic
socialist party is now the president's
approval rating look at this his highest
point in two years looking after his
State of the Union CBS Evening News poll
72% of the American people approved of
the president's State of the Union
remarks about immigration so by the way
if you're a Republican especially in the
Senate will talk to Lindsey Graham
tonight you know it's time for you to
take a stand do your job and actually
fulfill your promises and stop being so
afraid of ever being courageous keep
your promises to the American people
will you know we'll see because if they
did that we'd be safer and as more
details about this compromise become
available here's the bottom line if you
are a Republican senator or House member
and you're too weak to take a stand then
it's probably time for you to retire go
home let somebody who's willing to fight
take your place and if Democrats they
continue to stole stonewall play
politics with national security drugs
coming into the country in this
brand-new deal that will find out more
about the president will have no choice
he will veto this and declare a national
emergency why because as
commander-in-chief the president has a
lot of perfectly legal options for
building the wall including look at this
10 USC 284 that gives the president the
authority to complete the quote
construction of roads and fences and
installation of lighting to block drug
smuggling corridors across international
boundaries of the United States by the
way offense can be defined a million
ways and of course the primary smuggling
corridors into the US are right there at
our southern border that's where 90% of
the heroin in this country comes from
those borders and that means that helps
put an end to the opioid epidemic in
this country
so tonight Congress has two options they
do their jobs they agree on a compromise
that doesn't weaken border security or
they can do nothing and they can get
left behind because the wall I predict
is going to be funded and going to be
built I believe the president is
unrelenting tenacious and is doing
everything and will do everything in his
power to keep his promise get this done
even declaring a national emergency
which may even happen this week and if
that's what it takes
fine that's what it takes he took an
oath to protect this country do you not
want to be protected and more secure do
we want to stop the cartels the gangs
ms-13 human traffickers drug traffickers
those that we haven't vetted that may
bring harm to our fellow Americans and
we look forward to seeing what this
agreement entails
I'm very do
and also of course when far-left
radicals inside the Democratic Party
when they're calling the shots like
congresswoman Omar well negotiations are
probably likely to break down remember
when she publicly accused Porter
security officials of torturing refugees
or when the first Caravan came and and
we had Border Patrol having to use tear
gas to protect themselves from rocks and
bottles being thrown at them remember
they were accused of gassing children
well tonight in our Hannity watched on
the radical extreme socialist Democratic
Party we're seeing yet another sad
extreme chapter unfolding before our
eyes again surrounding congresswoman
Omar for a group that constantly tries
to claim the moral high ground on
everything now the Democratic modern
extreme radical party has an
anti-semitism that is now running amok
inside that party look at this over the
weekend Omar was lampooned for a series
of anti-semitic tweets pushing a
conspiracy theory quote that Jewish
money was behind support for America's
closest ally in the Middle East the only
democracy there she tweeted that it was
quote all about the Benjamins
now after some pressure from some inside
her own party she's quote apologizing
for offending Jewish Americans problem
is this is nothing new
oh they know who she is they know what
she has said in the past she's been
totally obsessed with hating Israel for
a long time once tweeting no apology
Israel has hypnotized the world may
Allah awaken the people and help them
see the evil doings of Israel and sadly
Omar's not the Democrat with
anti-semitic eyes in 2006 her colleague
congresswoman Talib authored an op-ed
for the Nation of Islam's publications
called the final call remember this is
Louis Farrakhan's paper and Farrakhan
frequently were refers to Jews as
satanic termites and worse also once
said that Hitler was a very great man
and that Jews were responsible for 9/11
this is a sick ugly despicable
anti-semite and those that write for
that paper associating with him like
congresswoman Talib
well it's not a good look for a sitting
congresswoman to start with now it comes
also as other prominent Democrats are
facing many of their own scandals
involving race look at the Commonwealth
of Virginia disgraced Democratic
governor Ralph Northam he is digging
himself into an even deeper hole amid
continued calls to set down following a
racist yearbook photo and his admitted
use of blackface in the 80s and after
vowing to stay in office to promote
racial healing really and then the
governor said this over the weekend when
he was talking about Virginia's slave
past listen closely to what he says if
you look at Virginia's history we're now
at the 400 year anniversary just 90
miles from here in 1619 the first
indentured servants from Africa landed
on our shores and Old Point Comfort what
we call now Fort Monroe and Wow also
known as slavery yeah and you know while
we have made a lot of progress in in
Virginia slavery has ended
schools have been desegregated we have
ended the Jim Crow laws easier access to
voting it is abundantly clear that we
still have a lot of work to do
now Northam arks during this entire saga
have shown his deep deep disconnect with
the people of his state who certainly
deserve better
indentured servants really unfortunately
the top three leaders in Virginia
they're all embroiled in scandal that
includes the Democratic lieutenant
governor just in Fairfax he is refusing
to step down after two various serious
allegations of violent sexual misconduct
and in one case he's accused of rape and
by the way the person making the
accusation as many people that she told
at the time backing up her story but
staff members are reportedly now
quitting refusing to work for the
embattled lieutenant governor by the way
where are all those I believe I believe
I believe senators we're gonna keep you
updated on the latest developments and
of course the scandal in Virginia it all
started with Governor Northam radical
position where he actually advocated for
out an outright infantis
I'd remember he said well first with the
live of the baby and make the baby
comfortable and then we'll let the
mother decide if there's gonna be any
medical assistance for the baby really
that bill legalizing abortion even
during the birthing process after nine
full months this is infanticide pretty
sick stuff and tonight that is only one
in a long list of radical positions of
this new extreme radical Democratic
Socialist Party including many who are
now running for the nomination of the
president in 2020 for their party which
brings us tonight to our Hannity watch
on the extreme 20/20 Democrats will
start with New Jersey senator Spartacus
Cory Booker comparing the green New Deal
to going to the moon and defeating the
Nazis and Booker's talking about
congresswoman Alexandria Casio cortezes
bizarre horrific new piece of
legislation now let's see that would
plan the end of consumption of fossil
fuels in ten years by the way the planet
is going to die in 12 years what's the
point by the way and seriously don't
write off congresswoman Acacio Cortes
and a Randy OS and disastrous plans she
is merely just saying and acting on what
Democrats really believe but try and
hide from you look at all of those
Democrats now coming out in support of
this this greed New Deal which calls for
no more oil no more gas no more fossil
fuels of any kind not even any nuclear
energy and it doesn't stop there
this bill that would eliminate airplanes
gas-powered automobiles and trucks gas
powered ovens and stoves by the way if
you like steak no more cows too much
flatulence and they commit co2 emissions
no more cows you better load up on your
steak and put it in a freezer and get
this or proposal also plans literally to
remodel rebuild retrofit every single
building in America to meet these insane
new energy efficiency standards of hers
and it gets worse
according to her office every American
is guaranteed a job and a
Valarie by the way whether or not
they're willing to work or not although
they're trying to back down on that part
of it you're talking about guaranteed
healthcare guarantee jobs guaranteed
vacations trillions and trillions and
trillions and new taxes 70% tax rate is
just the beginning for her and for those
of us who are willing and able to work
well but that is just one part of the
Democrats insane push to radicalism this
new platform look at Elizabeth Warren
she wants a brand new tax on wealth you
know that means you're saving cents
money that has already been taxed after
you pay 50 60 cents of every dollar if
you manage to save anything she wants
another bite of the Apple and by the way
40% when you die they want another bite
at the Apple another 10% of you live in
New York they want half again you pay to
die in America senator Kamala Harris
wants to end all private insurance a
hundred and eighty seven million
Americans wiped out of their private
insurance and by the way to put in place
a government-run health care system
called Medicare for all Kirsten
Gillibrand also says the same no more
private insurance listen they're now
more socialist than then their crazy
cousin Bernie from Vermont and Senator
Gillibrand also wants to completely
abolish ice as do others this is the
party of higher taxes open borders
eliminating ice late term abortion and
government control of all industry and
every aspect of your life they're going
to take away all your insecurities and
they're going to promise you health care
and housing and daycare and college and
and a job and a vacation okay and then
they're going to nationalize the energy
industry how did that Obamacare thing
work out keep your doctor keep your plan
and save less in other words they want
to take capitalism the very system that
is the envy of the world that has lifted
more people out of poverty than any
other system in history and flush it all
down the toilet with no hope of ever
getting it back destroying the single
best wealth producing structure in the
history of man even poor people in
America compared
and their lives in most cases if you're
not homeless
you know do they have running water do
they have toilets that they have
kitchens that they have refrigerators
freezers and able to cook I've been to
some of the poorest housing projects in
America I've been inside so ask yourself
for those values that will make America
great are those values that will improve
your life at all do you think anybody
with money is gonna stay here they're
going to leave like they're leaving New
York New Jersey Illinois and California
in droves tens and tens of thousands a
year 400,000 new residents in Texas and
Florida no state income tax